[Applaudissements]
apprendre à prendre c'est ce qu'on fait
depuis qu'il est tout petit à prendre
nous permet de nous adapter de changer
et adapter nos comportements à la
réalité et à l'actualité du moment
aujourd'hui dans la jeanne combien parmi
vous ont dû changer leur comportement
par rapport à la crise sanitaire
actuelle aujourd'hui je vous parlais
l'écologie mais les théories qu'on va
voir ensemble peuvent être appliqués à
ce sujet il arrive des années de travail
et à la défense en eau dans une tour au
40e étage depuis mon bureau je voyais
les limaces passé les couleurs de l'as
est changé toute la journée en dans les
cours
les réunions s'enchaînent les projets
doivent être livrés vite les appels vers
le monde entier se suivent et il fallait
toujours plus vite
chaque minute chaque interaction est
compté il allait les années je fais
partie de ces personnes qui chaque
premier dimanche des soldes dans les
grands magasins pour faire son shopping
j'étais tellement content de rentrer
avec les chars message pour pouvoir
essayer
vêtements et à 22,4 me porter l'écologie
la neige dans des romans bien sûr j'en
étais convaincu comesa je recycle et je
triais je mangeais dieu quand c'était
possible les produits de ménage des
verts l'écologie au quotidien
il ya plein de personnes il s'en moque
et ils l'ont bien trouver une solution
alors le réchauffement climatique
je travaille toujours là les france mais
j'ai changé j'ai pris du recul et je me
dis mais qu'est ce qu'on a fait pendant
toutes ces années je travaille toujours
à la défense et j'aime toujours son
énergie son effervescence sa capacité à
reproduire a créé à partager à innover
et aujourd'hui je la veux différemment
aujourd'hui je me demande comment sa
capacité à lâcher que notre place des
solutions les solutions pour réduire
l'utilisation de ressources naturelles
valoriser ce qui existe déjà on a créé
pendant des années on a produit pendant
des années des solutions pour protéger
ce qu'on a des solutions pour préserver
plutôt que de détruire des solutions
pour régénérer
plutôt que de puiser je n'ai pas envie
d'être comme ces personnes
j'étais sur le titanic en train de
prendre tranquillement leur repas en
train de danser pendant que les navires
cool
prenons le viera maintenant quand un
système va trop vite il est difficile de
l'arrêter
il faut agir maintenant
maintenant et à sa propre échelle alors
crié au cycle et c'est très bien c'est
un bon début mais ça ne suffit pas ça ne
suffit pas si on continue à produire à
créer si on continue à produire aider et
à créer des produits sans tenir compte
des impacts sans tenir compte des
impacts de nos choix sans tenir compte
des impacts des projets sans tenir
compte des impacts des projets que l'on
aime parmi le coût environnemental de
chaque action et de chaque produit
existe les secouer vraiment plus élevé
que l'on imagine aujourd'hui on a bien
plus à perdre qu'à y gagner en ignorant
ce sujet je sens maintenant
alors du coup je me suis transformé j'ai
fait ma rue on reprendre les armes de
léa salamé dans le deuxième volet du
documentaire demain j'ai fait ma vue
c'est une expression que j'aime bien
c'est fini c'est une expression qui
montre qu'on a cédé par un site saccucci
qu'on est devenu plus fragiles
généralement fusad à table et
paradoxalement plus fort je me suis
transformé commencé appris à transformer
mon monde parce qu'apprendre ça
s'apprend alors je vais partager avec
vous au travers mon histoire
les composantes essentielles
vas-y partager avec vous qui vont nous
permettre de s'adapter en permanence à
l'actualité confie à prendre nous parlez
vous adapter et à prendre en continu et
l'état d'esprit qu'on peut adapter
aujourd'hui pouvoir à rendre les
s'adapter à l'actualité à prendre c'est
créer un modèle du monde créé un modèle
du monde et pouvoir combiner tous les
modèles qu'on a appris depuis qu'on est
petit alors je vais vous raconter mon
histoire fin du printemps 2010 8
j'assiste à des conférences celle de
cyril dion sérignan à la fondation
goodplanet je me suis dit chouette je
vais pouvoir le rencontrer en savoir
plus sur son document cadre un plein
d'espoir et de bonnes idées et la
tonalité que je n'existais pas pour
faire ans comme les autres
j'ai réalisé par un commentaire par sa
parole par les questions du public
une autre réalité le ton était grare
j'entendais les émotions je prends les
connaissances des chiffres de la menace
de la réalité de la situation dans
laquelle on vit c'est et les plus durs
les plus difficiles à entendre à
comprendre et appréhender
si une des réalités qu'il tellement
difficile à apprendre qu'il est plus
facile de la vie y est qu'il est plus
facile de l'îlot de l'ignorer il est
plus facile de rester ignorant et de ne
pas apprendre je prenais conscience je
prenais conscience de la réalité en
juillet 2018 les effets du réchauffement
climatique continue à augmenter
c est la strophe naturel
ces catastrophes qui
de plus en plus graves chaque année
foehn une ovation tempête en août 2010 8
nicolas alone ministre de
l'environnement à l'époque démissionne
ligne outils il nous reste deux ans il
nous reste deux ans je me pose la
question et je le dis mais pourquoi ce
chiffre marque un nouveau site et me
pousse à apprendre nous pousse à
comprendre a essayé de lire j'ai
commencé à lire à regarder toutes les
vidéos à pouvoir en savoir plus la
curiosité une composante essentielle du
de l'apprentissage du coup j'ai riche
assure m tout est interconnecté tout ce
qu'on fait est interconnecté et tout
cela à jessains sens il faut que cela
ait un sens il faut que cela se fasse
sans qu'on puisse agir et à prendre et
nous devons tous apprendre pour faire
face à la crise actuelle
chacun a sa propre échelle chacun peut
agir avec ses capacités et son domaine d
expertise pour moi
la professionnelle de l'apprentissage la
réponse était claire
je veux aider à la transformation je
vais accompagner les personnes à peu
prendre ce qui se passe à donner du sens
et à apprendre et une régulation sur ce
sujet j'avais trouvé là un objectif se
fixer un objectif fixé un objectif est
un composante essentielle de
l'apprentissage
celui se fixer un objectif est ce qui
nous permet de diriger notre attention
là où il faut
la tension la tension est le premier
pilier de l'apprentissage seulement
nouveau scientifique cell chasse de la
tension est ce qui permet deux
elle est directement droit de but et la
main de notre objectif diriger notre
attention c'est ça va éliminer les
distractions éliminer les distractions
voir se concentrait sa demande de
l'effort et de la volupté
alors dites moi personnellement j'ai
éliminé toutes les distractions les
outils les luttes les notifications des
grands magasins les notifications et
j'ai dit stop à ces messages qui nous
envahissent où sa demande de l'effort et
de la volonté pour les personnes qui
connaissent ce syndrome
mais j'ai fait l'effort de changer et
grâce à ça aujourd'hui je n'utilise et
j'achète pour se donner que ce dont j'ai
vraiment besoin en ligne ces
distractions
j'ai libéré beaucoup beaucoup de temps
cette opération ses bénéfices mon île et
invite à gagner en motivation pour
pouvoir justement continuer à faire des
efforts et motivation est ce qui va nous
permettre d'agir agir quand on apprend
on doit s engager activement
l'engagement actif et le deuxième billet
de l'apprentissage
on va s'engager activement il faut
saisir l'information on doit aller la
chercher
que le travail est différente elle son
cerveau continuer à apprendre de
différentes manières et travailler du
différend faïence et canton de la dgi
pour l'environnement celui sur le gâteau
agir rend heureux comme dit yann
arthus-bertrand tester
et savourer ce sentiment positif est une
récompense une récompense est une
information qui va renforcer notre notre
comportement c'est dans ce village un
retour sur l'expérience positif ou
négatif
le fidèle va permettre de vous diriger
dans votre apprentissage auparavant fit
pas pour pouvoir bien profiter de cyrus
avoir détecté et l'identifié ces
feedbacks a laissé site de l'observation
elle nécessite de léo
ça nécessite aussi de la première manche
et de l'humilité à prendre c'est aussi
accepter de faire des erreurs à prendre
c'est aussi accepter de ne pas être
marqué tout de suite accepté
et persévérer quand on est dans des
situations difficiles comme maintenant
peut-être et du coup cette semaine en
situation de dire que je vais continuer
et que je sais c'est pas grave je suis
en période d'apprentissage et je
continue à m'améliorer
c'est un état d'esprit c'est à
l'éternité
les progressistes peut m'expliquer
l'alcool dans deux clubs français c'est
accepter accepter aussi de ne pas être
paraît tout de suite deux rêves de
dédramatiser sa propre erreur
dédramatiser les erreurs des autres
comment ça je porte un gilet en matière
synthétique et je parlais peu le baril
on est aujourd'hui dans un environnement
qui nous permet pas qui nous permet pas
de d'agir vraiment en conformité comme
on devrait le faire pour respecter
l'environnement
quarry bay si c'est important de
s'entourer
c'est important de s'entourer des bonnes
personnes
c'est important de de s'entourer des
bonnes personnes bienveillantes qui nous
encouragent des personnes qui nous guide
dans notre apprentissage des personnes
qui nous inspire je me dis qu'on l'a
fait des erreurs aussi et réaliser des
et la musique il ya des modèles ont
appris qu il faut d apprendre quand on a
aussi un cheval est content on va
apprendre c'est bien de travailler et
d'apprendre ensemble on apprend ensemble
en collaborant grâce à vos retours sur
expérience
on a aussi besoin d'apprendre et d'être
des conditions et dans une dans des
conditions de sécurité psychologique
persique et la sécurité psychologique
l'ajustement vous permet de dédramatiser
les rares alors tout cela nous permet de
consolider notre apprentissage pour
consolider notre apprentissage
demande le père net consolidé son
apprentissage s'est passé au mode
automatique
c'est à dire l être capable de faire les
choses
automatiquement ces facilités par
l'accessibilité l'accessibilité des
objets qui nous entourent par exemple
aujourd'hui si on a besoin d'avoir des
dés par exemple au jour aujourd'hui on
est à disposition du gel hydraulique
pour que le geste soit plus accessible
l'accessibilité est quelque chose qui
est très bien écrit et très bien décrit
par les neuroscientifiques notamment un
professeur de stanford qui s'appelle jb
fogg qui travaillent sur le design
persuasif et ses théories aujourd'hui
son sont utilisés pour nous rendre à des
applications smartphones ça serait bien
qu'on puisse les utiliser pour d'autres
raisons
donc comme celui des aussi son
apprentissage
c'est effectivement d'avoir les bons
outils en 2019
l'augmentation des magasins en vrac a
été de 41 %
c'est devenu plus accessible et tous les
jours nous sommes de plus en plus
nombreux à trouver des solutions et à
chercher et à marcher pour modifier
notre environnement et rendre les gestes
plus facile quand on a tout mis ça en
place et qu'on a une organisation qui
nous facilitent les gestes tout cela
devient automatique et on est dans la
consolidation
aujourd'hui on a les technologies les
outils qui nous permettent de trouver
des solutions
on sait que la collaboration fonctionne
mieux que la compétition on sait comment
faire émerger des intelligences
collectives
on sait comment fonctionnent les
neurosciences et les autres sciences
humaines à 20 h tous les jours
on sait comment prend les décisions
il est quand même temps qu'on agisse
tous en france pour trouver les
solutions pour finir je partage avec
vous cette phrase de l'enfant j'ai
entendu à la marge pour le climat
l'enfant disait la maman maman
le climat change et pourquoi on ne
change pas si je le connaissais ce petit
garçon je lui aurais dit oui tu as
raison pour toi et pour toutes les
générations à venir
on va changer on va apprendre et on va
transformer notre monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]